Which is, I mean, this is a controversial
thing to say, and I've, I got in trouble,
or one of my podcast guests, Gavin
de Becker, uh, the security, uh,
Guru, uh, got in trouble on my
podcast talking about the primacy of,
of intuition here.
Like,
like our intuitions are actually really
good for detecting something that makes
us uncomfortable about another
person, right? And this is,
this becomes politically incorrect, really
fast, right? Because it's like, you know,
if you see a guy on an elevator who
makes you uncomfortable, you know,
Gavin's advice. And I think, I think
the real st advice is just don't get on.
But there are many people who get on just
because they want to prove they're not
racist, right. Or they're not,
you know, it's like, and, and, uh,
I actually know someone who was
in a situation like that, uh,
and it didn't work out
well. And so, I mean,
intuition is bad for so many things.
We,
we have terrible intuitions for
statistics and Britain probability theory.
And it's like where we're reliably,
you know,
whole careers and Nobel prizes have
been won on, you know, the people like,
you know,
Danny Conoman have,
have shown us how, it's not only
that our intuitions are bad for,
for these judgments, but the reliably
bad, and we can understand there's this,
there's a structure to how bad they are.
But for judging people who are dangerous,
you know, who give us the, who makes,
who make the hair stand up on the
back of our neck for reasons we can't
understand, um, you know,
for where the eye contact was
wrong or the, or the, or the,
just the, the way they will,
you know, I mean, just like a,
what's called a witness check,
you know,
like someone comes up to you and
engages you and then they look to,
they just kinda look to check for
witnesses right now. Like, people don't,
aren't aware that that's even a thing,
right?
But when like that body language
is very salient to us and,
and, uh, there, there are hundreds
of things like that, that, that, um,
we immediately fee that prompt,
you know, an intuitive response.
And these are intuitions that are,
you know,
from a self defense point of view are
worth listening to because I like the
worst case scenario is you wind up being a
little rude. They're like, sorry, I'm, I,
you know, I can't talk.
But, um, uh, people are,
you know,
people are very dogmatically being kind
of trained to ignore those kinds of,
those kinds of intuitions. And what do
you think those intuitions are? Like,
what do you think intuitions are like
when you meet someone, you go, Whoa,
this person feels dangerous. Like
what is that, what's happening? Well,
there's a lot, you know, the gays
detection is a big one. I mean, we,
and what people do with their eyes is a,
is a,
is a major variable in just
how we feel that, you know,
the relationship is going.
Um,
but it's,
uh,
and there's their micro expressions that
we notice in people that were not aware
of noticing. You know, like,
it's just, there's the, this is,
this is not well understood.
Uh,
and we're bad judges of whether someone
is telling the truth. I mean this,
this has been fairly well studied.
I mean, there are people who,
even people that work for the FBI or not,
you know,
much better than chance and
detecting whether somebody is lying.
But there's just,
we get so much information by,
you know,
body language and being in somebody's
presence and we get it so fast that it's,
um, again, and it there whether
we understand it or not,
there are evolutionary reasons
why this is so, I mean, if,
if we've evolved for
anything as social primates,
we have evolved to detect stuff that
just is a precursor to violent intent in
others.
I think it's just gaze or do you think
you can sense the energy of someone?
There's certain,
well,
the movements that people
make when they're thinking
about hitting him. Oh yeah,
yeah, yeah. A certain like there's
like a twitchiness to them.
I got while pulled back like
almost like a spring or a bow.
There's like a feeling you get around
people that are looking to hit people.
Yeah. Well, there's the, but again, all of
that still vision, but there's, you know,
I mean, who knows where it detecting
pheromones, where we could,
we could be detecting people's
level of, of stress. I mean,
just how tuned up they are.
Um, but, and this goes beyond,
this is beyond just physical
violence. This is just, you know,
detecting psychopaths who are, who are
manipulative. I mean, just detecting,
I mean there, there are ways to spot
people line, uh, you know, I mean,
just, you know, they're,
they're tells like, you know,
too much information, you know,
like a pit people who are giving
you superfluous is a peripheral,
was information, uh, as an overcorrection.
And they're anticipating that
you're going to doubt their story.
And so they're filling in blanks that
you don't even need filled in. Right.
And it, and it's there sort of patterns
to, to sort of tee to that. But,
uh, and again, we, we,
we pick up on a lot of this stuff
without consciously being aware of what's
going on.
We just know that that's like not a
person I want to spend any more time with.
Right. Uh, but I, you know,
so there may be more of a literature
on this than I know about,
but a lot of this is not well understood.
And I may have people like Paul Ekman have
done a lot of stuff on Mike, you know,
micro expressions.
Um,
I mean that goes back probably
30 years at this point. And Yeah,
there are people who are outliers who
are great at detecting micro expressions
where they really, they really
just understand what's going on,
but it's not a w and an
AI eventually will be,
if it is not there already, we'll be
much better than we are doing this.
I'm so scared of that service
here to them getting that wrong.
Micro expressions are funny because
they remind me of microaggressions,
which is one of the,
one of the weirder social justice warrior
things like w things that used to be
just slights where someone was just
like slightly rude, not, not even slice,
just like, where do you come from? Right.
Space space of that accent. They're like,
oh, like what? So it away
from where your parents from.